live here let me fix
something
stream
cool we got a bunch of stuff to do
today we got a bunch of stuff to do
today
uh I guess I can leave the title as is I
wanted to fix up the snake in the
breakout stuff wait hold on didn't
I I'm pretty sure I told these guys that
I would give them some time to try it
themselves though let me just double
check I might have to change the
titles so yesterday I
did let me see the last couple days I
ported this like contributor breakout in
pong code
now [ __ ] that's a good question I got to
call
them okay so Nathan is probably on this
maybe he'll drop by later uh I kind of
want to get the mobile working today
properly is that
feasible I mean there are two things I
could do right now and maybe I will I'll
make it depend on you know whether one
of these guys drops by or not and uh
need some help on stuff but I guess the
two things at the moment with puffer I
really want to get this pong and
breakout these Sims really clean and
Polished they're very basic Gam
but like doing these is going to help me
optimize the way in which puffer pushes
code from python to scyon to see I
really want to cut down on the boiler
plate there's way too much of it right
now um but also I keep showing this
freaking MOBA demo to people and it's
pissing me off that the models aren't
that good
p.m. yeah let's let's do the mooba for
now and then if Nathan or Noah drop by
and they need help on this we'll do that
I'm going to change the stream
titles let's just
do uh RL
MOBA uh NC plus
[Music]
whatever I think that means we're going
to be be working on one of the puff
boxes
today uh most
likely
yeah okay so I think that there are a
few things to start with let me just um
let me get my thoughts out here because
I haven't looked at this project in a
little bit
Jacks okay so here was the sweep there
were some weird bugs as well with the
with the
port but I want to
see what happened here
yeah there's something
screwy
so 20,000 uses that's a
much oh
uh
huh wait wait why are there 1.4 billion
step runs
here why did it do that what are you
currently doing hello um I have this
game you can play it
online but I have this game that I've
built here it's like a miniature version
of League or DOTA uh the we have models
that run in the browser but they're not
very smart at the moment and uh they
used to be smarter but then I ported
this whole thing to see so I could it in
the browser and some stuff got messed up
so I'm currently trying to figure out
how I can make these models actually
perform correctly and what's wrong with
our training setup yeah you can see them
kind of do stuff there's the tank
dashing in it's kind of a fun little
project um but yeah that's what I'm
doing at the moment we might switch
later today to
do uh pong and breakout here these are
contributor code right uh I had I asked
the devs of these original projects to
try
to to try to get these things training
correctly so I was going to give them a
little time to do that before I jump in
because I think it would be good
experience for him but yeah at the
moment I'm trying to figure out this
MOA cuz something's screwy something's
really screwy so this is going to be a
probably today it's going to be a mix of
uh experimental analysis running some
experiments uh trying to inject some
logs into the code and doing a few
things around there it's probably going
to be the main
thing receive SL tank these numbers are
very very
high how the
heck yeah the thing I don't know for
sure is like how is it at 10,000 over
here
maybe it's cumulative maybe it's not
getting
reset that would make sense what if the
environment is not getting
reset I think I might have hold on I
might have pushed a bad
pushed I hate this demo file as well I
tried so hard to make this demo file
simpler um but there's really not that
much I can cut out of
it's that I cashed God damn it I did
this for the uh the GPU Drive guys they
wanted to be like we needed to be able
to make the environments
reset but this is broken training
completely so this is why our
experiments aren't
working uh I have to I'm going to have
to add a special case in here so that
this will
work which I really hate doing in this
demo file
equals I guess we just have to do this
based on the name
and one of these days I'm going to find
a cleaner way of doing all this stuff
but it's always hard to come up with
like clean demos that do a
not it looks like some things have been
broken
uh where's the name
there should be like an M
name but I don't see
it mode config args config
maybe okay this is loading the
completely wrong
config so I have to figure out what's
happening with this
folks we're paying the piper today and
actually fixing this MOBA environment
cuz like in the last week I've shown
this to so many people and it's so
obnoxious to have to say like oh yeah
you know it used to work before I ported
it to see
go okay now I'm remembering what I wrote
here so
okay let's figure out why it's loading
why is it loading this weird
config
okay default that's fine
config okay so I need to figure out
where that config variable gets
this is really cool you're teaching
machines to play mooba oh yeah and the
fun thing with that MOA is it runs at a
million steps per second per CPU core so
we have unlimited data why did you port
it to
see so that I can do
this play it
online C compiles to web assembly syon
does
not so you guys can actually play with
it that's why I've been recording all
this stuff to see from scyon uh scyon is
just as fast but uh you can't play it
online so these make for some really
cool
demos it is also it's really not any
more complicated than the scyon either
like once you get used to it I think
that the cev is just as easy as the scon
there's really only one there's really
only one major feature uh in scon that I
miss and see which is memory views like
you end up having to make uh somewhat
obnoxious like index getter methods but
other than that it's
comfortable I don't know I've been on a
c kick lately
config or path in file
paths key. read ar. default
config that seems really wrong doesn't
it ar. default
because okay I see what this is so you
go
you read this okay so this is just
loading all the various configs up
me so why does it show like config do
Grid or some weird
thing it's definitely loading the right
file right
here I'm hoping that I'm not about to
find like some crazy
bug config is config ocean grid.
any
key I'm worried that we're loading like
the wrong
config for specific environments here I
have to figure out now the thing is I
was going to do this stuff but I have to
figure out exactly where this is coming
from because this could be the issue
with like replication of some stuff
right we were having some replication
issues with a few Niche things I don't I
don't know when the uh the circumstances
this occurs or if this is even a
bug but
uh this Mer's looking into
base
and poliy okay so these are all fine
where does the config variable itself
get set I think that the most likely
thing is probably it's like being
injected and not getting used it's like
some extra redundant default which is
what I'm hoping oh right here
argument this might just be leftover
garbage I think that's the most likely
scenario is that this is leftover
garbage right what happens if I do
config PPU
drive and then are these the right
parameters
fix not as bad as I thought literally
just a redundant
uh okay now I got to figure out the name
of this thing I think it's just ARS en
where's the name of GPU Drive in
here base
did did I not put this under the top
level
somewhere ARs and
no back
base I guess I didn't that's bad on
me uh but we can just do
GPU
drive I guess we'll just special case
here for now I hate having the special
case but
yeah okay so there we go now this should
be
cashed now this should be cashed or
uncashed I
mean speaking of which let me go check
on the GPU Drive um guys slack I always
forget to check the
slack
he oh hold on
it okay well I'll have to help them
pretty soon
then I like all these collabs we got
with Labs so GPU Drive is this GPU
accelerated driving Sim and uh looks
like they've made it faster and when you
hand me a fast Sim puffer makes it very
very fast so I've got to update some
Integrations for them but at least what
I've done here they should not break
their
demos mode
train let's see what this does does this
very
nice this m time is obnoxious um it
should be way faster than that but we
got some weird multiprocess
bug
so oh actually maybe the caching thing
will fix that though that's an
interesting
thought okay so these lines actually are
not going to tell me anything
huh some of these might be
good
level I wonder
why why it ran longer and longer
experiments if it wasn't discovering
reward they're also very
oscillatory because like the games will
end at weird
increments Norm
reward U this looks okay like it does go
up just not super stable
something is very weird with this ELO
chart
because even if it's not resetting the
environment
well I guess a lot of wires could be
crossed here huh cuz we weren't
resetting the environment at all and
like some of the stats are based on
that yeah I could see something being
weird
there oh we got a lot of folks today
welcome
YouTube for context here maybe I should
just leave this up in the
background um while I'm like looking at
stuff but you you can play this
online it's not super fun yet but it's a
nice little MOBA
game you know you got abilities here's a
dash let's do like a dash strike AOE you
got like this assassin character you've
got like this tank character that's
super broken because he has like this
huge well he's pretty slow but then he
just like can drain in an AOE like this
got a self heel little mini
MOBA we're trying to get RL working on
it I'm trying to think if I just want to
rerun
completely I don't want to just have to
do a full sweep from scratch
maybe I can check
level maybe that's what I'll do let me
see like which of these gets the highest
level
characters dire level let's do like
radient level mean
there are like a couple of these that
are higher but like none of
it's I don't actually know what the mean
level should be come to think of it CU
this is just recorded in
snapshots like you can see it going up
over time so training is
occurring I'm kind of curious about this
run
damage
dealt
killed I mean this actually looks may be
good what about like
level oh yeah no over the course of
training you can see
here it does
increase but not not amazingly
right I think we can do way better than
this so I guess we are just going to
have to start a new sweep on
it it's a little
disappointing I'm trying to think if
there's like anything else I can extract
from this in the meantime
well I think we'll probably regardless
we'll keep working on the mobile on this
side today and try and just like try to
understand some of the stuff that's
happening
yeah see if I can catch like any errors
in the data or things like
that but this should just be able to go
up over time I would think
this graph bothers
me I'm trying to think
here why would ELO not go up over
time it should be able to find better
and better hyper parameters
I would also really like to
know why this thing is
crashing so maybe we'll do both I have
two boxes right
commitm
bug fixes in demo that
bug could it be that your things forget
St it's not there are like
infrastructure issues going on here what
I'm doing is I have this setup that
launches a whole bunch of different
experiments and then the different Bots
play against each other and we see which
one is better and you should be
discovering better ones over time so
it's not like I have one really long run
I have a whole bunch of different
experiments uh and there's just
something screwy here
now I actually see a crashing
here that's a legit
bug player pit 79 Target pit
zero okay we're going to save
this and I think what we're going to do
is we're going to
rerun on this box we're going to run
this sweep
I didn't recompile hold
lines you know I feel guilty
monopolizing these boxes
um and not running stuff on them
constantly but like
really just when I need them I need
them and don't want the overhead of a
job scheduler on my cluster
either ah we forgot about
this uh we should fix this today as well
this is kind of Jank that I've left even
though it's the dev Branch I would like
to fix this issue today
I wonder how I do that do I have to
like I think I have to just add like rib
H or whatever to
my
is the
binary Oops I meant to do
r.z I can tell I'm a little bit burnt
out because like things just take a
second to click in my head
here I don't
know my tendency is always to just keep
pushing though for another couple weeks
another couple weeks before I just take
some RNR
I thought I was going to be able to like
really reset on uh Sunday and like chill
out a bit and get a good night's sleep
and and reset but uh I got roped into
going to some crazy party in SF and I
was just like too much
like I'm bashing python Files come on
what am I
doing okay but this should actually
work include
need yeah there we go you just need
railed in the
route that's actually pretty
easy then I can just Sim link it from
all the individual environments Maybe
maybe what we'll do is we'll not make
this one a
sweep hold
on I mean these parameters should still
be good
right what happens if I do a
billy like
this I don't trust this clip coefficient
is the
parameters let me try um what was the
really long run here this one this one
looks
stable right nothing is crashing
maybe so much weird nich RL knowledge I
have that's
obnoxious like why is the KL going up
here right why is the KL doing this and
like why is the value loss exploding
like this why is the policy loss
exploding right like somehow all these
things are happening but it's still
training I don't even know how this
reward distance thing is a positive
number
troll I wait how is
this this reward distance
coefficient this has got to be fake
right okay here's the new sweep
right so
we're going to do a little bit of
figuring out here so this I see this
stupid reward distance metric is
there oh CU you didn't delete this
[ __ ] here
right well it's it's nulled out here so
I think I think it's fine
regardless I would like to delete this
just in case
used and
now there's so much stuff you can
do just like waiting for this
to to
work so if I'm looking at the reward
functions
smoothing it's not consistently going
up but that's it's like there's so many
layers to this like it's not necessarily
bad that the reward is not going up
because it's a PVP game right so the
enemies are also getting better I mean
reward XP should definitely be going up
and it does for a little bit but then it
stops going up
Victory okay so you can see here that
they like games are
finishing so like lots of games are
finishing and mostly radiant is
I have to understand this dumb value
function thing at some point because it
keeps finding these crazy parameters
that go off the rails if you keep
training I think it's maybe okay for now
though
I remember I actually did retrain one of
these and it didn't do very
this the other thing I could do right
now would be to make the model size be
um a sweepable parameter
right the model size should be a
sweepable
parameter yeah we're going to do that
we'll make we'll make it so that this
thing can Auto scale its model size
maybe do I think it's a capacity issue
though How likely is
that it is a very small
ask H I don't know if I want to do that
just yet I think I'd rather have this
sweep
run what else can I do in the meantime
to push this forward it's the tricky
thing with these projects right
on it's interesting that it like
immediately learns to use its abilities
almost immediately right
health because this is sketchy right
that it does like
this I think I was trying to get all the
games to be desynced so you get smoother
learning
do I guess the path forward here should
be
to let this sweep run for a
bit play around with the moit and some
other stuff today while this is
running and then once we get a
reasonable set of hyper parameters that
look like they're not insane then we
should probably do a run in which we
track ELO over the course of a single
experiment
in order to see if we can get like a
stable run that keeps making
progress and then once we have that
that's kind of when we can start scaling
along other
axes yeah I think that's a pretty
clean way of doing it so maybe we will
do a hodg podge of stuff today uh I will
I'm going to go use the restroom then I
will think a little bit more about
this and then we'll look at like some
other environments or something there's
lots to do here there's a lot to do
here actually let me message the GPU
Drive guys because that would be a
decent
so I had a bit of a think here oh wait I
have a
reply got to finish merging talk to
Brandon
okay so GPU Drive guys waiting on them
still um this we're going to have to
wait on
experiments so I actually have a rare
day where I have some brandwidth to do
other cool stuff
how about we Port the grid environment
to
see I kind of was wanting to have like a
really basic mini grid
thing and I do have need for a grid
engine
anyways why don't we go do
that I'm going to update the stream
title yet again
engine
see not really a grid engine what is
it oop
see
whatever oh yeah this is actually nice
yeah we'll let this thing just chill
here all right this is a very roundabout
start to the
day also way later of a start than I
would like but my schedule got all
thrown off this weekend
file so copy grid.
py grid
you know this is going to be
fun this is only 200 lines it's very
simple why don't we just get to have fun
today you
know whenever I can have fun and do
something useful that's a good
day standard
struct or do I want to have like a grid
end
struct I don't know let's be really
brained about it for now and then we can
always
refactor it's always the fun way of
doing
it wh
and let's do unsign charar these are
just going to be flat like
this yeah there we
go this is a
here let's just do oops I forgot as well
to do a type
death and now we can just do grid n in
it grid
n man I love super Maven because it
knows exactly the way that I write my
code it's basically just a typing buff
grid oh no because it has a
grid
and then we need to do unsign
grid and then we need to do unsign Char Flo spawn positions
can't let me make sure I'm not going to
get burned here taking suggestions
without checking
them agent
colors observations rewards with eight
it's in Vision range agent
speed
discretize expect okay this is
grid things are all fine and now we have
to do the allocator version of
this this is actually kind of cool
because I've written like this exact
type of code uh several times so it's
getting better and better at
autocomplete yeah that's actually
correct out of the box isn't it very
nice okay we Cal the
grid we Cal the observations which is
almost
correct um into OB size is going to have
to
be wait two
times M Vision range +
one yeah it's going to be
OBS size times obs
size
so
reward agent
Maven it like doesn't try to think for
me it just does all the really dumb
stuff is exactly what I want
these I don't like the way that this
agent positions thing is
mentions by mentions you mean DMS or is
there a thing you got a launch
there
[Music]
was a
bug in the plotting
what what is
this
what what is this
do I really have to go see what this
thing is I will see this will but I'm
going to be mad if this turns out to be
[ __ ] where's the
this where's the
paper where's the paper
man where is
no 2018 you said no you said no and then
yes like
okay
preconditioned storing and manipulating
prohibitively
large preconditioned
tensor wait is there are there two
versions is it this this
qualities wait
what this
is run a swall okay I can do that it
there's a pie torch implementation of
this thing I assume
slow
gradient M
[Music]
think this isn't bad right this is just
one
wait gradients of
Weights is
this when it says gradients of Weights
like it's not one Matrix right like I
don't know how they're
treating I mean I can drop it in like
blindly to test it for
sure why is it that this random 2018
paper is like now suddenly coming back
and I also I can't tell the complexity
of this thing because I don't understand
how they're representing the weights
here right
like oh Matrix
case where's the general
case brother what is wrong with this
General tensor
case I would love to know how slow this
thing is because I can't actually tell
looking at it what they're doing
disregarded I mean I can go run a sweep
on this I I guess there's no reason I
can't do that right now I was in the
middle of reporting some cool stuff to
parameters they're using for Gemini
flags as well
as oh that's interesting
oh there's a bug
okay zero
Shimp me see what this thing
is you know I'm always very suspicious
of
these
like cuz 95% of the time you just waste
your time right
man this is like we're so close it's
like it's annoying will cuz like we're
so close to um we're so close to the
point in RL where I'm going to be able
to actually evaluate stuff like this but
like in my mind we need like a decent
number of fast environments in order to
actually do this
properly I like I can run it on Atari or
whatever but like Atari is dumb you
know I mean I have this but like this
needs a little bit more work before it's
it's fully stable and then I have one
other environment in the works as well
but that's going to take a little bit
I'm very
confused this simple will
work if you use a
single yeah I I'm very confused as to
what this thing is doing is this trying
to confute igen values n like over
massive
matrices isn't that a very slow
operation am I just completely
wrong I don't know what this p is here
either
oh this is just
a block
dim that's basic
wait what block dim 512 is that like I'm
pretty sure most of my networks don't
even have hidden dim 512 is that
supposed to be like blocking over weight
matrices or
something apparently the simple is
slow I mean I'll gladly try this out
will um you know the one thing you
should realize at the moment like you
should know at the moment is like I'm
trying to get RL to the point where we
can even do this type of stuff correctly
right because right now like the default
way of doing this like at the moment you
would just like run Atari on one run
aari on the other without touching the
hyper parameters at all like in order to
do this thing correctly you need um a
bunch of different environments and you
need to run full hyper pram sweeps with
both optimizers and you really need to
understand you know how they both look
and RL just is not there yet we're
almost there with the stuff I've been
doing love to see this tried yeah I mean
I can do stuff with that like we have
these so far like to our Atari is decent
we can train Atari at 30,000 steps per
second one GPU but then like these are
hundreds of thousands so you see we've
got two Atari M's right here I'm just
I've been trying to convince more open
source people to contribute
implementation ation of these things um
but they take a bit of time to write you
know like you can't just like get Claude
to spit out a shitty
implementation of uh of these things
they have to be
good like I just ported this this was
from a contributor I just ported it to C
so we can play with it on
web it's pretty
fun I think it's uh kind of too hard the
ball keeps getting faster and faster so
there are a couple small things to fix
but you know break
out yeah we're going to have more of
these what I'm trying to do right now
you know minig
grid so this just technically exist and
Jack already but like I hate jacks or RL
um and I already have something that's
like 90% of this I just have to
implement like keys and doors so I was
going to Port it to see and then put
this online so you can have minig grid
on
web that sounds like a reasonable thing
to do right just put minig grid on web
this has 2.1k stars I should have done
this a long time ago but I better late
than never right
nice I love that yeah so I we'll just
make these playable
online technically I have the re one of
the reasons I didn't do it is I have a
colleague who's been working on uh
similar stuff but like his thing is
going to be for I think primarily for
more complex environments and like while
you could technically Implement minig
grid very easily with his framework I
think just having like a standalone C
thing would be really nice cuz like this
whole mini grid is probably like 00
lines of code right like I just 400
lines of code you just replace this
library and this one should run um
probably like 10 million steps per
second per core with how simple this
thing is
right like yeah the OB size is not even
11 by
11 hi how's it going it's going pretty
well oh shoot we got a lot of folks on
YouTube here I should probably actually
write some code so people don't get
bored here but yeah Will dropped by and
said there's a new Optimizer that's
probably I should look into for this but
what I was doing here is I was about to
start trying to do this stuff and
see is is the farama still
running uh I don't
know have the M yeah well I mean that's
my thing well I'm fixing it now right
like I'm I'm carrying the torch for
now with Puffer
I don't know the farama was Jordan and I
don't know what Jordan's
doing I know that there's still some
people doing maintenance on stuff but
like it's a God awful thankless job so I
don't blame a lot of people for having
know stopped on a lot of
stuff am I allowed to like blast nurs
reviewers yet
or do I wait I think I wait until we get
like the formal rejection and then we do
a proper
[Laughter]
blasting I don't know if we've had have
to go
look but yeah let's do this real
and where is the secret
project the secret project is currently
3,000 lines of C it renders Basics I
have like basic rendering stuff working
um I need to Port the rendering to a
Shader because of how big it is in order
for it to actually render the bigger
Maps correctly I need to Port the whole
render to a Shader I need to add some
like extra VI features and I need to do
a lot of testing and experiments and
then it'll work I'm working on it like
off stream on the weekends essentially
at the moment I should be working on it
in the evenings it should be done
already to be honest but I've been
really burnt out by the end of the day
lately so
uh yeah I need a couple weeks to kind of
just like take it a little slower and
then we're going to burn back on in a
bit not Minecraft
are
you RG streamer and deep
stream
popular I've never heard of either of
those I've never heard of either of
those what are those
yeah I've never heard of either of these
man I don't
know handling realtime streaming maybe I
don't
know I think you find a job by building
cool [ __ ]
[Music]
right speaking of which I really want
some people to build more of these Atari
M I want people like coordinating I want
the original Seven like the seven M from
dqn implemented Ultra Ultra fast for
puffer so the standing for YouTube folks
you don't need RL experience prior RL
experience to do this you just need to
be a competent programmer um they're
usually like a few hundred lines each
you don't have to write in C if you
don't want to you can write in scon it's
like python it's very easy uh it just
takes a little bit of work and uh it's a
really good way to learn a bunch of cool
RL stuff like these were written by
contributor that I then ported to see
from scon so like you got this little
pong game in here right this is a pong
that runs super fast we've got breakout
right classic guitar games they run
super fast and now uh I basically
challenged them to go get the models
training on these which should be quite
easy given how fast they
are you can play them now on puffer Dogg
and we need more of
these how is it
scyon so it's like python goes to scon
goes to C pretty much like the easiest
in my mind that's it's actually easier
to just write directly in C now but uh
if you're not comfortable doing that you
can write in scyon and it's just as fast
there's
Nathan wait
oh I just realized that you're here I
don't know my brain is not working today
yeah Nathan
um challenge for you is to get the
models training on that now I think
you'll learn some good RL if you do
that it'll probably involve some tweaks
to the environment you know some tweaks
to the training configuration and then a
hyperparameter
sweep maybe some debugging of
observations and stuff
Nathan has a lot of ongoing challenges
fair
enough hey I'll do it if you if you
don't want to do it I'll do it but I
figured it would be a really good RLX
for you
this is an obnoxious grid slice is it
not yes this is an obnoxious grid slice
okay already had a trained agent in
sweeps was rewarding hitting the
paddle got to run it with a score reward
you should just you should basically
just steamroll it like you just you have
so much data that you should steamroll
it I will say that I think that the pong
game is pretty hard at the moment so I
don't know if there's something with the
ball speed or the paddle speed or
something I don't know how closely you
matched the original um but it feels
really
hard I it seems like there's something
different with the acceleration of the
ball because
like I could be wrong but but it seems
like you can like move the paddle and
like you can slam the ball in pong or
whatever the Atari version and you can
like send it across the stream uh the
screen like to the other side before the
opponent can get there cuz like the
train policies that I see on pong a lot
of the time it'll just be one move right
it'll just be like the ball comes they
slam it down into the side of the wall
and then back across before the opponent
can get to
it oh the YouTube stream is doing great
today welcome everyone
I'll go back to Dev in a second because
uh you know that's the content but I
will take a moment to quickly say this
is all free and open source you can play
some of the environments on puffer Dogg
you can look at all the code it's in the
dev Branch I will link it in the chat
and all I ask is that you start the
repository helps me out a ton back to
code so what we're doing here is we've
got this grid based environment and I
think we're going to just get this fully
ported into C put it on online and then
add some missing features in order to
just replicate exactly uh this other RL
Library a mini
grid and we'll just have that you know
way faster and way simpler in puffer
properly maintained in like a tenth of
the amount of
code that'll be really
nice
so in uh
suppose r r
CC and then m.
there we go so we don't have the nice
memory slice syntax from cython so we
replace this with a loop
here is there food in minig
Grid is that a
thing I tried to match some assembly
implementation but it's hard to find gez
okay so you actually tried to do that
okay that's
good I mean you can also just like play
the uh the Atari game right you can like
play the original and see if it feels
about right but I think it's solvable I
think it's just really hard I can't tell
for sure it took me like five minutes to
be able to score one
point oh the other thing I got to figure
out how to do and I haven't looked on
how to do this yet because I don't write
the HTML for this it's just like
compiled with M script in but I want to
add like your contributor information
either here or like here or here um you
know I want to put that somewhere so if
I don't do that soon remind me that is
important
do
done to
R is Rand percent height
that's weird
right I'll leave it for now but I'm
pretty sure this is a
glitch 's
empty add food
so you don't need to do W this is just
while
through I don't like this can
scoreboard frankly I think the next step
is to replace the the ball with the
puffer fish so that it bounces back and
forth
I got to get like I want to like get
just like a few frames of the puffer
animation like pixel art puffer
animation so like you can make it so
that like you know it like when you hit
the ball it puffs up and then it slowly
deflates on the way over or something
like that I think that would probably be
pretty funny people would get a kick out
out of
that you could have picked a square
fish I mean the Minecraft puffer fish is
square but that's
copyrighted there aren't really any box
fish the ball doesn't have to be square
though it can have a square bounding BLX
that's fine
classifier I don't know why you would
use RL for
that they're not inter like they're not
interchangeable Technologies right like
supervised learning and all like these
are not inter interchangeable
technologies that do the same
thing the point of RL is
to learn from Less Direct feedback like
a reward signal right usually with IM
like image classifiers you have labels
that's
good so we have the spawning
now I don't know why I didn't Port this
earlier this is going to be so stupidly
easy it's not even
funny I don't know there should be way
more on the puffer G by now it's just
like I started doing this in the last
couple weeks only and
like I basically just need to take a
reset and uh like buckle down and do it
one of these weeks and just just focus
on like making stuff for
it well to be fair there are a couple
unsolved problems I have to do before I
can really scale that side uh there's
too much boiler plate involved right now
with the c environments I have to figure
that
out it can use a low reses image as a
signal we driving a car for example
right TR yes so the reason that you do
that is that that's not an image
classification problem right in an image
class ification problem typically uh you
know what the image is and you're trying
to train a network to predict what the
image is that means that you have the
label right you know that you know the
image can be all of these things and
this is what the image is so you have
the data to train directly end to end on
that and that is a much better training
signal with track Mania right you're
trying to teach the car how to turn or
like what buttons to press in order to
steer and in that case you don't have a
label right you don't know what the
correct thing that the agent should be
doing is all that you know is like hey
if the car gets there faster and doesn't
crash that's good so you have an
indirect signal or a reward so that's
what RL is for so RL is less sample
efficient it's a less efficient method
of learning than uh supervised learning
in most cases but it lets you learn from
like much more vague signals which is
the really cool thing and it lets you
learn like on simulators and such
about vectorizing M and C did you do
that for any of the MS you think it's a
significant difference uh I noticed a
difference uh the thing is that a lot of
my environments are multi-agent natively
Nathan so like if I'm already simulating
M that have 4,000 agents then I don't
need to vectorize on top of that but if
they're single agent then you do need to
probably vectorize you can ignore it for
now if you want to I think it's probably
substantial overhead but like the thing
is it should be 10 lines of code I kind
of just left it to you as an exercise to
show you how easy it is like I'll do it
if you want me to but literally like in
the environment where you make like like
EnV right self. en whatever you just
make that be an array like mstar right
and then you just assign num M and you
write the loop in C instead of or in
scon you write that Loop in syon or C
doesn't matter instead of doing it in
Python and you're
good is RL models more like energy based
models I haven't looked at energy based
models into any amount of depth and not
in a long time um RL is about learning
from signals uh sort of vager signals
it's like I don't know what the exact
correct thing is to do in this case but
I know that if if I'm playing this game
here right like I don't have labels for
what I should do at every single frame
here right like I don't know if what I'm
doing now is good or not necessarily but
I do know that if I like well I have to
actually be able to beat it in order to
do the demo which is which is hard
because the environment is not easy um
come on can I get a point yeah there you
go so I know that that was good right I
know that it was good that I got a point
so I can learn just off of that one
signal that's what RL can do
TBH the GPU is the bottleneck for all of
the super fast
M's well it should be that's your goal
Nathan but like you're not bottlenecked
on GPU if you're training below a
million steps per second on that little
environment you should be able to hit
over a million steps per second on one
GPU at least on like a good GPU
yeah so you can play around you can play
around with a couple of these m's on
puffer GG puffer Dogg we've got some
simpler ones we've got like this cool
multi-agent snake this one actually has
some agents in it already and then you
have the puffer MOBA this is like a more
complex one that's fun and play around
with this I like doing this because it
just feels fun to play
GPU is
shitty well once you think that you have
it reasonably optimized Nathan you let
me know and then I'll run it on my one
of my
409s million is million is Baseline for
like simple en very simple en Baseline
is a million for 490 and I think you can
go faster than that to be honest that's
like with like a little MLP lstm policy
so that's with memory included you can
go way faster if you're not doing that
um but
LIF oops
and agent speed
minus all right
cool and uh this is kind of gross I have
to do I don't have slice
indexing no that's okay we'll just do
it then
wait left right
bottom wait
left why is there no
top oh because it's just the
same that's fine
yeah grid
offset so less than
left
that and the
column do all the columns
do less than left oops don't know what
this is doing probably there is some way
to combine these I just what I'm doing
here is I don't have access to this nice
slice indexing this is the only thing
that I miss in C is I missed this
syntax CU you end up having a couple
couple gross Loops for things like
so this code does this portion of the
code does get a little bit
longer but then this portion gets a
little shorter because we don't have to
pred declare
X I should replace spawn position
with two lists
there's no reason that has to be
continuous
either I think I can just do int
canand and then we just do int y equals
and percent
empite I think Y is divided by Nite
right or n with and then X is percent
with like
this and then we don't need
dis we definitely don't need
dis we do n of Y or
grid
ah in
Adder be the offset at Y and X if
grid is
[Music]
empty we set the address to be
this
color we set the r to Y we set C to
X we
increment yes we increment the agent
index which means we have to set this up
here agent
this is such a little silly thing but
one of my favorite things about not
working in languages where everything is
a bloody class is just saving that one
row of
indentation it's so obnoxious to me
starting all of your code for all of
time like one level indented
or two levels I mean you still have one
level but
yeah so
um this is an error the way that this
thing is is made right
here this is before I figured out this
trick
here I uh I realize that you can just
pass the actions tensor to the
environment directly and then you never
have to copy it which is kind of cool
uh find
interactions yeah
thing I don't know how I feel about this
uh discreet versus continuous nonsense
to be honest
I think I'll keep it for now but it's a
little
so I think that actually having the
discretization is not necessarily bad on
its
own the part where it becomes bad is
storing it like
this
um but the thing is if I store it as a
float
right I kind of want to convert to float
but if I store it as a float then I'm
checking integers versus
floats that's really bad
right what's like a clean weight handle
data that could be floating point or
could be integer I wonder in this
context I think we'll just do the
discreet case
now we're just going to
do cre case only
why H it gets the index incorrect it can
see because I have to Flat index here I
was going to have to do
that
why this is actually a
float cuz we are keeping the positions
in um
we're keeping the positions
no longer need these explicit casts
anymore which is
cool if it's food then you set to
empty and then this is food
reward and
wait did I get this right hold
on dis D yeah no this is totally fine
here so I don't know why I have this
double f
I
checking twice there's something weird I
was doing here I don't remember what I
was doing with
so this should be
YX and this should be like Des
Adder okay and then this is
des adder's
food you eat the food you set the
rewards
right and then if it's empty this is
also D Adder right
oh I see this is why you're checking it
twice you clear the food right you clear
the food
first and then if it's
empty there's technically a weird Edge
case that can happen here but it doesn't
really
matter
Edge
spot doesn't really matter though we
don't really care that much for
now so yeah we set the grid Adder to
empty so this is moving the agent then
we move it
here continuous position
continuous position
update R that's I just
see okay and then this is the random
respawn thing which I think we still
need now we just
do oops
what I don't know why it's doing this
else this should be in
observations oh because we messed up
with the way that uh yeah this doesn't
need to be like this you get to just
remove
this and this all goes
here and we are set
environment uh let's go make a test for
it and also we need to Port the
rendering I forgot about that part so
that's basically trivial I
think uh I'm almost tempted to just go
copy the snake one because it should
really be that basic
right yeah
like I basically have the same render
code for
these it should just be this with maybe
some slightly different
colors and then let's just go check
Rd Pi
maybe rectangle it's almost the same I
think we have oh no it's not quite the
same I was using because I was using the
puffers
is Graphics right all right well we'll
do the silly thing just for the heck of
it
color UV quartz of
do star zero
Z zero right like this and then
color yeah it doesn't understand what
I'm doing
here oh cuz these aren't colors right
these are
be cord of
seven rectangle like
this
rectangle then this is going to be 5
7 38
4 wa
a 1 two three four five six seven it's
good to
me and I'm sure that the colors are also
wrong let me see what I did
here grab
knit window is going to be width times
cell
size same thing right height cell
size offer lib grid do not need encode
anymore this is C we also do not need
the RL dot you want the target fps to be
10 um this Sprite sheet
path is going to be obnoxious I believe
module. spit puffer
chars where's puffer
chars hello
uh how does this even run if they don't
have the
assets but whatever we'll just assume
that this is uh puffer
chars puffer chars
PNG and then we'll just add texture
2D star Puff
be when der puffer is going to
be puffer
chars
cool no longer need
this turn the
renderer and now
see how I do the rendering on
this it is a little bit different
right I think it'll be easier to just
Port this that way I don't mess it up
versus uh trying to use the the snake
one we'll keep it
around but uh this should just be M Star
m r agent
positions yeah we don't need agent
position positions
anymore
exit
drawing clear background is going to be
colors I mean it should know the
background
anyways but I'll go grab the colors
anyways
I actually don't know
if do I need any colors
here I think I don't I think I just need
to know the
62424 right this
is color 6.4 yeah yeah that's the
background that was easier than I
thought it would be
TS is going to be cell
size
go main R
equals m h into r z meing
c do R
Min
equals then this is
n he over two is does m have a
height does
what oh this is like a local render
thing isn't
it yeah I don't need to
care I don't need to care too much about
this I think CU we're going to just do
Global render for the
web but I think this is actually a lot
easier than I thought
offset pile it's going to be Grid at the
address if pile it's
empty
continue we put the braces on here
what's two
wall P's
wall then
we colors of
rectangle and this is not very nicely
optimized I'm being kind of lazy
here uh desk
direct sure and then draw
texture that's
fine then this I can just do
white
and there we go anything missing from
this no that looks fine so we added a
little bit of code with this renderer a
screen of code barely over a screen of
code I'm going to go use the restro real
quick and then uh we're going to make a
little test for this we will get this
running on web we'll decide what
scenarios and things we want to Port
over I mean it's only 300 pm. we should
be able to get a lot more stuff done on
this today uh let me make sure that the
Moa experiments are still
running uh yeah I still have the Bell on
this
so yeah you can see that the stats are
now
correct yeah this ELO is more reason
reable cool we should be good
I like how the stream count goes up when
I go take a
break does each M have a set of
predefined
parameters uh for this little thing here
depends what you mean by
that like what do you mean by parameters
like they're customizable and configure
in VAR but configurable in various ways
usually yeah in this thing you're going
to be able to specify various different
tasks
C found it oh yeah that's what you meant
I I didn't understand the question yes
we have the hyper parameters and
sometimes end config parameters are in
the Ines that config system has gone
through like five different iterations
and I'm not fully happy with it but it's
way better than what was there
easy I don't know eight D is going to be
Visions
five and
h why did this at
Malik I always I always want cic never
Malik dang it it did it here
too no more no more malaking
we only cic we never
Malik allocate
grid we call this with
width height and the magents
completing is the internet out or is it
just not autoc
Play Float food
reward and Float
snake I'm assuming Dev branch is
broken
quick I think I just broke a bunch of
stuff uh recently
well whatever this is is not supposed to
be happening so I don't know why it's
rendering
these
um but I it the M name
is mode
train does it not compile or something
cuz it runs here I'll fix it cuz there's
clearly like the render mode is wrong or
something I mean here I think it's
literally just this
okay so this now trains on my
system
it's
from yeah so I'm assuming it's not
compiling correctly on the environment
setup if you P if you uh build X in
place
I think I need to add like downloading
rib to the setup or
something my bad this is just like
growing pain with all the new
environments getting added so
quickly to the dev Branch at least I try
to keep the main
stable but uh you know it's a pain I
know so I will fix that for you if you
can figure
out no that should be in the root
directory if you if you run that command
does it show that it's building the
snake environment or no
copying you might have to clear the
build directory and
rebuild you might have to clear the
rebuild cuz I changed like I changed a
few things with how it works let me just
make make sure I'm not telling you
garbage snake C snake
pix hold on this might be the wrong
build
I might not have ported this to be
trained in train
error from s
snake for
yeah my
bad there's a bunch of build Shenanigans
I've been trying to
simplify it's not that complicated but
it's like it's just a bunch of repeated
obnoxious
code
um why don't I see breakout in
here wait why don't I see breakout in
there should be breakout in here I don't
know why it's not
I will PR this
live just give me a few minutes
here and then we'll go back to the grid
en um essentially it's just like there's
some build Shenanigans associated with
like the python is fine the C is fine
when you put Python and C together uh
things are less
happy I'm fixing that real quick for
you my
snake
pix do not need this
anymore
undefined
symbol and
drawing do I have RB in
here I do have rayb in
this might actually be a code mess up on
my
part though I am including rib here
correctly
you
rebuild would just be
cash in fact I think it's probably just
cash it's obnoxious but happens
now where did thing
go there
we're still going to have Linker errors
huh well that's the wrong
file so that's probably
why wait
what oh SE
works set up clean I I don't know man
the
setup I know that building removing the
build just deletes it so
whatever yeah I just there's some wires
crossed because you got to I realized
like there have been so many different
versions of this cuz I use snake as like
a Dev environment to figure out how to
do a lot of this stuff right so I did it
in Python first and then I did it in uh
scyon and then I did it in C right and
then I did a bunch of C like things
around it so yeah there's like there's
some stuff
local this is going to give
me better
positions oh I did mess this up somehow
let me see grid agent R
ageny spawn
colors OBS uh rewards with height agents
Horizon Vision range
speed discretize food reward expected
miscount gridge agent R agent C spawn
position cans agent colors
missed
no observations it's working good I that
should be a good build you can let me
know if I mess anything up there if like
something isn't training or it's like
crashing or doing something weird let me
know like Essen EV I'm in this phase now
where I know how to write all the code
that I want like all the SIM code I want
uh can be in
C and I can make that pretty clean but
then when I go to bind it to python that
process is a little bit Jank and uh I'm
still trying to figure out ways around
that because you basically you have to
go through scyon and then you have to go
to buy Python and the scon is like a
bunch of redeclared code and the python
file also has a bunch of stuff that has
to get passed through to scon to see
it's kind of a mess
Ed
to
oops
food
whatever oh I y'all got to tell me when
I'm like I forget to resize my terminal
so I'm not typing off you know
underneath
myself tell Meb
issue no idea what's going on that makes
two of us buddy no it's uh I'll show you
so we've got
um if you check puffer Dogg
we've got like a few different games
online this is the most complicated so
far it's like this little mooba uh and
then we also have simpler environments
as well like we've got like classic
citari stuff got like breakout here and
the goal is to have a bunch of these
like simulations in order to train RL
agents on and the key is that in order
to make them good for RL they have to be
stupidly high
performance so what I'm currently doing
is I'm porting this like grid uh
environment thing to see so that we can
compile it for web and have it be nice
and fast uh and then I'm going to try to
slowly build this thing towards this
like standard mini grid environment that
people use a lot in research so that
there's just like a really easy
Standalone ultra high performance
version of
that occasionally I kind of get lost in
like the rapid debugging
cycle check out puffer what advice would
you have for someone wanting to learn
all this stuff to it depends on your
experience level right is this like new
to RL new to ml new to AI new to
programming right it depends on where
you're starting at
programming in general then yes that
then there is a lot to learn for sure
um I don't know I think just generally
like
making very simple little games or
something is probably a good way to
learn just trying to keep things very
simple um and learning Basics by doing
trying not to get too caught up in
have yeah um I mean yeah this is like I
mean I've been doing reinforcement
learning for like the last seven or
eight years right it's things get more
complicated there I will say that the
thing I'm doing now at the
moment well designing the way that this
stuff is set up requires
uh you know all the RL experience and
all the AI um actually implementing the
simulators is something that any like
relatively competent skilled developer
you know with like a few good years of
solid experience could
do because these are like I mean I'm
essentially I'm just writing games but
I'm writing I'm writing simple games in
a way that's very very fast and very
simple is all I'm doing at the
moment I have some cool bits on um if
you check like the main YouTube channel
there's like my thesis defense which is
all the stuff that I've done in that
space and then I have this newer video
like the RL Iceberg video that has a a
pretty good overview of the stuff I'm
looking at and reinforcement learning
now and it's like it's sort of a
midpoint it's more accessible than the
other stuff out there at the very least
thanks so much watched your PhD video
had no idea but it was very interesting
the iceberg video might be a little bit
more accessible
um yeah it's I mean there's a lot in
this space right I would say that RL has
got to be the hardest area of AI uh to
work in just because of the amount of of
engineering it takes to do stuff
well I mean it's doable it takes like it
just takes time right you got to like
you got to like this stuff and you got
to spend a lot of time learning is all
it comes down
to the math isn't that bad I will say
which is one nice
thing
index that's upside
wor I know I try to point stuff out when
I see like useful little tidbits while
I'm working on stuff like
this well when I say not math intensive
relative to other areas of AI like
I'm very comfortable working like my
math background that I that at least the
portion of my math background that is
useful
uh well you definitely need to know like
tensor operations and stuff but really
to understand how stuff works under the
hood it's tensor calculus which is a
really fancy way of just saying calculus
applied to matrices which is not much
harder than standard calculus um so the
math is actually there's some fancy
things but it's it's really not as bad
as you would think it's kind of like
first couple years of an engineering
degree if
that
um and the portion that like the
portions I use daily are really just
like being comfortable with manipulating
multi-dimensional array data in various
ways there are few like there are a few
things that are a little more complex
that are useful but for the most part
it's kind of just engineering all the
way
down like the single most important
skill in what I do here is just being
able to write good code you know just
write good code and not make a mess of
things what's the Big Goal you're aiming
for at the
moment uh at the moment it's mostly
about getting all of these different
it's about getting like all these
different simulations
online like this is like a miniature
version of League or DOA right so this
is like a more complex environment
obviously I'm missing animations for
stuff and whatnot you know this is a
fairly complex
simulator I want to get these guys
actually playing the game like if I get
them unstuck here you can see right like
he actually will do stuff I need to
improve on these models I need to get a
few more environments onto this page and
I really need to create like a very
clean way of training models on a bunch
of different environments very very fast
that's like the key I think to improving
the field is getting all this stuff just
simple and fast because it doesn't exist
now like it's not out there in a way
that's simple and
what are the prams that tell me a run is
uh is training well it depends on the
environment for the Snake Game you're
probably looking at like the mean snake
length
right um You can also just render the
game and see it or something like pong
or breakout it'll be whether or not
you're actually winning the game
right for the Moa it's a little bit
harder because uh whether you're doing
well is relative to your opponent so you
need ELO so we have like ELO scripts for
it
oh I guess it's this axis that's wrong
huh
check I'm assuming just spawning this
wrong right oh yeah I'm totally just
spawning these guys
wrong can I use 100% of GP with sitting
at 20 to
depends on the
configuration you should be able to get
it to be a little bit faster with Das
Das vectorization uh
for what it's worth uh if you were to
use like clean RL or sp3 or
whatever like vanilla any of like the
standard Frameworks your GPU would be at
1% utilization
is you should be able to get higher than
20 or 30% for sure like 100% is hard
because you got to realize that like the
networks are really small and you're
chugging tons and tons of data like with
the snake environment I think you're
probably chugging on the order of like a
terabyte of data per hour through the
model actually more than
that now that I think about
it if you're counting the forward and
backward path separately you're probably
chugging multiple terabytes of data per
hour uh on one GPU with the snake
environment it also you should realize
like you I mean you should notice it
like it should be training basically
instantly as well you should see the
just immediately start
learning
yeah you can try that I think the
default setting for multiprocessing is
at least it use two cores so that it'll
uh it'll basically run the snake's
environment in the background while
you're running the policy
still you only need two cores the snake
environment is so fast that like there's
no way you're going to need more data
than you can produce with two
failed to open so I need to get this
file
what uh that's
weird sure
did you do dash dash mode
train cuz with the multiprocessing
here I mean I'm getting 800k train just
off of this
and this is on my local box which is
slow so I'm getting 37% GPU and that's
already at 850,000 steps per
second there's quite a bit of data
transfer overhead
what system are you running this
on like is this on Linux
code it's a Linux Docker though right is
it like perer tank or something cuz that
should
work unless I'm
mistaken cuz I'm on Windows here yeah
puffer okay it should definitely work in
puffer tank
though I actually don't know looking at
that what the heck would cause that cuz
if the environment runs it should run it
should run
multiprocess does any of the
multiprocessing work cuz if none of the
multi processing works like on the other
stuff then it's probably a system like a
system weird
thing regardless though like even on One
Core that snake m is going to run about
a 100 times faster than whatever other
RL environments you might like normally
play
with I mean you're still going to have
this thing training stupidly fast
regardless
then there could technically be some
Shenanigans with like Raa being
initialized or something but I wouldn't
think
so okay I'll have to figure that out I
think that there might
be like that issue just might go away
anyways once I clean some stuff up um or
it could be system related but I think
regardless you're going to be able to
train that snake environment at like
500k plus anyways like that environment
should be trained within a few minutes
if you're just playing around with
things I mean heck you could literally
if you wanted to you could take Cuda off
and train one snake environment run on
each core if you wanted to and it would
probably run over 100K per CPU core it's
that
weed will
work unbreakable
error raining is using
61%
GPU well yeah the m is going to use a
little bit more because it has a bit of
a fancier architecture with it
uh to it I should say
um you should be getting faster than
200k either way with snake though
right snake should be over 200k
easily easily
easily but I think you should like the
the MOBA running that fast should kind
of tell you though right
like environment complexity doesn't mean
that we can't run fast it just means we
have to design a little bit more
carefully right
what's wrong with
this for
good doesn't work though there's nothing
on the screen
Y and X
set X
connection error is
different is it trying to pop open the
window window during
training I just double checked that if
you have render mode set to human it'll
do weird things but render mode should
not be set to that by default yeah it is
okay well that's why if I don't know
what setting you're using of it but if
you open like the ocean environment. py
file uh I I the patch that I sent you
should have
included setting the render mode there
to RGB array which would make it not pop
open the renderer
that's
why if I miss something you let me know
there
black window still opens okay
so that should not be
happening let me see if hold on give me
a second and I'll see if I can find what
the heck is happening there because they
really shouldn't be doing that
yeah
y got
agents we'll fix that properly in a
second let's see what your error
s oh I
dumb I forgot to commit this my bad
you'll probably still get the broken
pipe but let's
see you can take a look at that
working fine okay my bad I forgot to
commit a file thanks for the
I'm trying to think what I want to do
with this
thing I kind of just want to go straight
to minig grid
here we should be able to do that pretty
quickly I lock in
700 to 900k GPU around 30% yeah so
essentially all the overhead the M time
should be really slow if you look in the
dashboard uh there's currently a lot of
overhead from Cuda transfer cuz the
operations are so small I will be
optimizing that at some
point I have some ideas on how to
optimize it it'll be a little bit tricky
uh but for the time being like you can
be content with the fact that literally
nobody else Nar is training that fast
like you're already training several
times faster than anybody else in RL
right now on one
yeah it turns out that when you go
faster than literally everybody else you
start having to optimize a lot of a lot
of
stuff like things that we're not bottl
next become
bottlenecks
right let go look at minig grid real
yeah if I so if I can wake myself up
here a little bit if I can just wake up
we can literally code all of this
today this is really really
agents in fact we can all do we can do
this all in one layer it's that
easy yeah this is going to be a million
plus per second no this will be 10
million step per second
honestly Direction it's facing
wait
one yeah this is
easy Direction it's facing is a little
different that's fine though okay here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to take a
few
minutes
um I'm going to take a few minutes I'm
going to go make a
shake um reset a little bit and
then we're going to try to just
Implement all this in one go I just got
to wake myself up a bit I've been tired
lately I'll be right back
[Music]
okay I thought about this this is
incredibly incredibly easy
I don't know why the heck I didn't do
this earlier this is so incredibly easy
it's just not even
funny mini grid base basically has a
goal Keys doors that's it let me make
sure the OB space is what I think it is
that's the only other thing I got to
check
I mean they have like a bunch of
observations and [ __ ] but
whatever does anybody really care with
that
stuff look at all these freaking
papers I mean these M are like
trivial that's so funny like the amount
of research that's been done like these
M are so so trivial
I mean we're just going to insta solve
all of these
right oh this is good because I can see
exactly what I need to implement here
okay they do have like these objects
additionally
there's
lava door key
en huh there's no freaking key
here 16 okay so this thing is not right
because that's not what it
is dynamic obstacles
this is just like abusing minig grid to
like Implement silly things right
okay so they have this extra mission
space thing in the obs
nice because like we're just going to
insta solve this end which is very hard
or whatever we'll just insta solve this
with vanilla RL and then laugh I
guess which of these is the
hardest it looks like that one
right
let's go for that
one doors keys
we'll do it's multi-agent as
well we'll go for 16 channels I guess
goal and then you need if I want to fit
this in
16 then it'll
be Warf for agent
oh I can't do this needs six different
doors so I'll have to do 32
let me just think how I want to
represent this real
quick eight
doors Eight Keys
oh actually this fits perfectly if I
want obstacles doesn't
lava man I can sacrifice the
food do I want to sacrifice the food
thing not
really I would also like to have the
four different agent types like that
it's kind of
nice hold on wait maybe do I have more
bits than I thought wait key
door isn't the obstacle thing kind of
dumb I need it how many of these used
obstacles
one two
three wait I only
see six different
doors six
keys
six
obstacles six agents is
24 and then I would have
eight I'd have eight left is that good
left let me try
this I think I kind of like
well actually it's going to be a little
different
right empty
wall gold can be
three or
or
lava uh two one
Oneal
three I have two more
five five
six uh this works perfectly so what I
was trying to do here uh I got kind of
stuck into this for a second I was
trying to find a nice way to pack this
so I used exactly 32 uh observation
types door key
door uh OB
one let me see if I did this
right
wait so there should
[Music]
be I have two do I have spare ones here
four it starts at eight doesn't
it this is supposed to be eight
manually so 8 9 10 12
13 14
one 2 3 4
8 okay so we have six of each of these
and then we have a few empty
spaces we hash F Reserve
1 6 7 five so we've got two
reserved uh we've got two reserved ones
here so we could actually increase one
of these categories to eight we could do
eight agents for instance that would be
kind of nice instead of
six eight unique agents
let me see if there's anything that I
missed from here that I would need to
use those
on I don't think
so I think I got everything
do I have an example anywhere of how
this Vision looks when it goes like
looks through a
door oh wait
here this one does
it ah it can see
it's like doing like breath per search
or
eventually yeah you can see it's doing
like
find num agents
eight objects
six yes
I'm going to have to do a little bit
more than just
um agent colors and such now
right I should probably add
um an entity
struct let's see what do we want not
tile
y X1 X1 Y is
fine and then we'll just
do int keys num
keys and
uh objects I think technically they can
have multiple of the same color object
in
here I don't really think I care about
that yeah we don't really care about
that do
we I actually think it can only H it can
only hold an object object
right think you can only hold one at a
time which makes it
easier held
object this we'll put the array at the
end and it should have a direction as
well in Direction
this withd height num
agents Horizon Vision range
speed that's
fine
discretize uh food
rewards I think we really need to with
that do
we expected
lifespan and Horizon is just
size we'll get to Ego srick in a bit
inter
actions don't need
this position cans I don't think I need
this
either oh we do need int
color color like this color Direction
something like
that our
rewards activations actions rewards this
is good
so we just do in
Grid this we get to get rid of a whole
bunch of shenanigans
right we just do uh agent star
agents we don't need
keys observations
oops actions
rewards we just do width height num
agents Horizon Vision range disc
critise that's
fine with
height num
agents Horizon vision
speed there going to be a nice little
environment and then we don't need this
don't need
this +
one set the grid set the
rewards that's
it so now with height
Horizon
Vision
e discretize we don't need this
anymore and we don't need this either
so this is almost a
oneliner I think we'll split this
one uh we'll split this one like
oops
Yeah you make the grid make the
actions like
this and we do
this we're calling it
grid and it's
simpler
rewards discretize very
yeah this is so much
easier
why Agent star agent right
I I'll probably want a version of it at
some point but it's it's so easy I as
we'll just write it
obnoxious I think I'll punt on this for
now and we'll leave the reset walls like
they
are it's only somewhat obnoxious won't
take that long
toga1 I don't need to do any of
these this is
fine uh actually this is a reset so I
kind of
do yeah we'll do it this way
let me prevent this AC from freezing me
second
what's this like funky graph paper thing
they've got going on oh it's just the
compression weird
needed
cool let's go get this to compile and
then we'll start adding
signature with height and agents Horizon
Vision speed discretized don't need
these
there that should be
cleaner I use variable food food
reward
uhhuh and then we have to actually make
some sort of
little environment right
go let's
see agents going be one
so d wall lava
coal
LT we're going to just comment this for
now
until we get the texture set
up cool so here we have our
thing it now
runs I'm tempted to just make the Sprite
sheet for this thing real quick but
I could just go make the Sprite sheet
for this thing real quick
it's five let's make uh let's go make
the Sprite sheet for this real quick why
not right
dude what the hell is this
rendering are you kidding
insane oh does this literally not have a
Sprite cheat
it's literally they're just software
rendering the freaking triangles one
pixel at a
horrifying it's literally useless to
have like an image version if it's going
to be that
slow and honestly like it's kind of
misguided in the first place to try to
like oh we learned this from pixels now
it's the same problem but
pixels well I was going to go steal
their Sprite sheet but I guess I can't
do
that no wait they have to have this key
right there like there's no way that
they did this key
they've got to have I
mean there's got to be a key somewhere
right
what okay I guess I just match it I
can't find their their dumb assets um it
doesn't matter we'll just match it
let me think 32x
32 it's got to be an 8 by8 Sprite sheet
I believe we'll do
um 8
by
4 I
guess so that's 1024
by12 eight
columns four rows okay
got
red looks like they use red
blue
green
we'll keep this up as a reference in the
background actually I think I want to
like just sample their colors
even and so it looks really recognizable
to
people oh you can't do it I guess you
can't like
sample noxious that's okay
though yeah
I do
this empty wall lava
orange what the heck is wrong with this
thing
why is my Color Picker this
and then they do like this squiggle
thing I guess
I really just want like this stupid
asset right I can trace it
one more
time it's
like I don't know why the [ __ ] I'm doing
this instead of just like you know
making it original
but I want it to look like kind of
recognizable okay well I'm not going to
be able to do this right now I like I
straight up can't trace things I don't
know
why I'll do it programmatically at some
point whatever we'll use this for now
and we'll just draw on
it dumb I shouldn't be wasting time on
this
at least get like something that looks
reasonable
reward should
be
now we should darken this a little
bit
we're going to grab the puffers to be
the
agents I kind of want to just grab the
uh the original pupper here
eight puffers perfect we'll make sure
that we tint
those and then we need the keys
the key graphic from
something it'd be really nice if I could
just figure out where the hell they had
their assets folder to be
honest I thought it was going to be
easier and then I realized that the
graphics are slightly more intricate
than I
thought but like they don't seem to have
a Sprite sheet anywhere as far as I can
tell
oh
that's obnoxious
so I'm not going to be able to like
exactly Trace stuff but but
um I mean I don't know what else to do
to get these assets
so I'm going to have to like do
something like this
got our stupid looking key
we'll improve on this at some point
honestly we should just like get some
new
graphics it's going to look very silly
anyways but we'll do this for
now um
okay six
Keys then we need
doors um I'm just realizing now that
they need to be able to be opened and
[ __ ] yeah I messed up with that they
need to be able to be opened and closed
uh let me think what I'm going to do
about that
colors is there a reason that the
objects have different
colors they shouldn't need them right
oh it's because they have this language
thing
stuff I kind of just want this to be
like a quick project where we do some
cool things and get out
I don't want to make this like another
big
project so I only
see these obstacles really don't do
anything for me
so and I should just be able to do
like one
key7 oh wait door
six yeah these these can just be
open
door
locked I need to allocate one of these
to
be uh this penalty thing I'm not going
use so we'll just do
okay so we got the six keys and we just
need the door open door
closed and
this how do they distinguished doors
being opened from closed
are we'll just make our own real
quick for now I don't want to be
freaking drawing assets all night right
I want to be back doing stuff
particularly like because we're going to
throw all these out anyways I'm
sure
here just do like this oops
wrong yeah I have it right I don't know
what's wrong with
me okay
and I just need a 16 pixel
bar this goes
down to be
blue
yellow green no wait
blue blue yellow green
purple
gray
blue
yellow uh purple is
oops I should probably just batch these
so I do them at the same time right be
faster if I can figure out these stupid
layers here
right yeah
there we
go oops
whatever I think we just do a gray and
we'd be done for now
1 2 3
4 5 six
did I miss one I missed yellow here
didn't
I that's obnoxious
just going to merge all these anyways
right
yeah it looks like the assets aren't
perfect
deal I just want this to be done so I
can have something you're not going to
be able to notice for the most
part there we go and
okay so now I actually have some stuff I
totally forgot to do the keys um but
that is super
easy just do like
okay we actually have a reasonable
Sprite sheet
now uh I do have to adjust the puffer
fish
characters I think we'll leave them for
now though because I really only need I
really only need the
now and the uh the nice thing with the
UVS
here I
over
sc8 so was it
n okay
be I don't know what's wrong with this
thing bad recommendations
there's no scale on
this draw texture
W oh no it works because the dust
rectangle is
um this scales it
right
yeah t s that should be good
it
okay but this is not drawing
U
is t wait tile
[Music]
eight this is
eight well like
oops still
this one is
percent this one is slash I believe
right this looks
correct Desir
is c times tile
size R time tile size T
size draw texture why is this not
showing
wrong there should be pretty much stuff
anywhere you look on this
sheet4 it's got to be the destination is
wrong right
can I like just draw this whole thing
real quick
textures what if I do 128 does this
shift
fine and what if i' say
like what if I say 128 128 what's this
do shrinks it
right this looks good doesn't it
times to
size they're very
weird they don't get
like CU this gives you
seven right and seven should give you
like this puffer here
best part of development is figuring out
why textures don't freaking
render it's so
silly I don't know if I just change this
to like 256
256 does do anything
oh that actually did do
something there's you can see the fin
right
here that doesn't make sense to me
because it's supposed to
be this is supposed to squash it it's
not supposed to affect anything else
well it's rendering over the puffer fish
for some
reason which I don't understand because
I have this rectangle drawn second but
sure is this not like recompiled or
something oh why the hell is this
here yeah
okay it was just rendering over it and
that's
puff no longer need this no longer need
this
yeah but
now uh we can
make make a scene
on
this e
cool
so we got some responses from people
which are like yeah maybe but they think
it's a little more complicated than this
so let's see if we can solve
okay maybe now it'll actually work yeah
that should do
it
nit was just and my get IGN
Norse what do they call this thing lock
to room
is you can only see three
this
one then we just
do uh
row zero
Adder
equals off
set
row
then seven oops we just making this end
real
quick
eight 8 9 10 11
then
12 like so
right okay so these are all the M's
set and then we have to set the doors
which is going to be Z
three seven right
one yeah
door
one the door un door open
yeah I think I'm doing this backwards
this
is is
three yeah this is supposed to be 97
s 15 by
7 and then this is now
three
11 39 15 11
cool last one is going to be door locked
five like
this and then we just
and this is
key
five so we'll do a nit locked room in
right or uh make we'll do make lock room
in
well we almost got it on the uh the
first try I think I forgot to Pat it is
what happened
here I have to pad this
eventually we'll figure out
had to do this without
padding in fact that will be part of
part of the New Port I
how's that actually how the hell is the
key
it oh yeah I don't know what the what
the hell this is but uh
huh something's writing over like memory
or some weird thing
yeah it's literally just memory writing
over okay there we go uh we're missing
one door here so let me see what
happened we did one 1 two
six
n
add three four five what happened to
door number
six 3 9
five door
open
five
lock
wrong I'm sure there's like some
[ __ ] memor overwrite thing happening
plus it's like the auto correct screwing
with my numbers without me noticing cuz
I'm tired I'm
sure yeah so there we go so there's the
key in the right spot then why is the
door in the wrong
this okay so there we go so there
is there is the mini puff grid
I don't know why the windows the wrong
size and such but that's
okay there's the goal state but I need
to
adjust quick because I realized
progress not fully done but um
this is
reasonable
and I have to implement like d and key
mechanics and such but all the state
stuff is
reasonable
um we got the assets or basic assets at
least which was a pain we got all the
stuff rendering
correctly the most part so I think uh
either tomorrow or Thursday whatever
I'll fix you know I'll finish this stuff
up we'll have like a couple of these
environments I just want to have like
some form of this grid environment on
GitHub
already not on GitHub I mean on the web
so we'll do
that and then we'll go from there
um
yeah decent bit of work I'm trying to
move my hours earlier so I can be
streaming earlier in the morning so I'm
going to go get some exercise get some
food get to bed early and then we'll
pick this back up tomorrow so thank you
all and uh don't forget to feed the puff
for a star bye